how's it going everybody it's warren and
avengers in game is almost
one month away and obviously the biggest
question right now is
how are the avengers going to undo
thanos's snap
obviously there are a ton of theories
out there right now in regards to how
the avengers can do this but i think the
most believed one
is that the avengers somehow will build
their own infinity gauntlet
collect infinity stones from the past or
the present time and use them to defeat
thanos
so the question with this theory is how
do the avengers make their own infinity
gauntlet i'll break it down in this
video but a quick reminder about my
giveaway i'm giving away 5 imax tickets
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain
okay so i must issue a spoiler alert
about this video because it comes from a
plot leak from somebody who claims to
have worked with marvel but his company
was fired because people were
leaking things and this user has been
partially verified by the moderators as
somebody that likely has relative
information or
spoilers i will only be talking about
how the avengers build their own
infinity gauntlet but if you want to
avoid all potential possible spoilers
for avengers in-game click away now
so this leak says that the avengers will
travel back in time
using the quantum realm this is
something that everybody pretty much
knows for the most part
the avengers realize that the only way
to undo thanos's snap is with their own
snap
so at some point in the movie thor goes
back in time and gets mule near from the
past and brings it to the present
this is something that people have
predicted as well thor going back in
time to retrieve mjolnir so he can have
two weapons or so captain america can
wield mjolnir
[Music]
however according to this leak thor does
not go back in time to get mjolnir to
use it as a weapon
he goes back and retrieves it for the
uru medal thor knows that e3 used uru
metal to make the original infinity
gauntlet and that uru metal is the only
metal that is strong enough to contain
the power of all the infinity stones
and from here tony stark is the one who
makes the new infinity gauntlet but
captain america is the one who wields it
so let's talk about how this makes sense
so perhaps e3 was a victim to the snap
or perhaps he can't make an infinity
gauntlet anymore because of his hands
regardless it doesn't matter because
thor knows that he used uru metal to
make the infinity gauntlet
the only uru medal that he currently has
is stormbreaker and he's not going to
get rid of that because it can kill
thanos
but in thor ragnarok hella shatters
mjolnir and we see it fall to the floor
right after loki summons the bifrost and
him and thor go up and hella follows
that would mean mjolnir's remains are
just sitting there thor could go back in
time to right after when loki thor and
hella leave and just
pick up the remains of mjolnir this
works because it doesn't alter the
events of the past it doesn't change the
future
thor collecting the remains of mjolnir
doesn't change what happens in thor
ragnarok
and then we have tony stark if there is
anybody who is still
alive that is capable of making another
infinity gauntlet it is tony stark
after all he did create a new element
and in the comics he has worked with uru
metal a few times
and we do know that the russo brothers
draw inspiration from the comics
but the main thing now in the movie is
that tony stark now has access to the
most technologically advanced city on
the whole entire planet wakanda
tony stark was able to makeshift
machinery and devices in order to make
his new element
imagine if he had wakandan technology at
his disposal
because now he does the biggest issue
would be heating the metal enough to
make it melt
which i'm sure with the combination of
tony stark bruce banner rocket raccoon
captain marvel and thor's lightning they
could figure it out somehow
so with uru metal at his disposal and
the most technologically advanced city
at his disposal tony stark creates a new
infinity gauntlet
and the captain america wielding the
infinity gauntlet is probably a
reference to the age of ultron scene
where captain america is able to move it
a little bit
[Music]
nothing so this makes a lot of sense and
seems extremely plausible
the avengers know they'll need their own
infinity gauntlet the uru medal from
mjolnir is just
lying on the ground after hella destroys
it and the combination of tony stark's
brains and wakanda technology along with
the rest of the avengers
should be enough to heat the uru metal
and forge another infinity gauntlet
so let me know what you think about this
do you think that we'll see this in the
movie or do you think that it'll be done
in a different way let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to avengers
in-game and marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
[Music]
woof
[Music]
you